before creation itself
there were six singularities
forged into Infinity stones hey
everybody so thor ragnarok is out
hopefully you've had a chance to see it
I've gotten so many questions about
where all the Infinity stones are where
the soul stone is so that's what this
video is gonna be about so just careful
for thor ragnarok spoilers if you
haven't seen the movie yet if you are
finding me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get everything because
there's a whole bunch of infinity war
coming before the end of the year and
there's giveaway stuff that i'll explain
at the end of the video - people were
like oh man is this whole stone gonna
show up during this there were so many
theories about where it would pop up I
thought it might even be inside Thor's
hammer but surprise surprise
there was no soul stone to be found so
people were like oh there's no infinity
stone but you have to remember that the
tesseract was in Odin's vault the
tesseract is the space stone so there
was an infinity stone in door Ragnarok
and because it seemed like Thanos was in
one of those post-credit scenes it's
like he's coming to collect the first
stone the first stone that we ever saw
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe I've
already done my post credit scene video
I'll link that at the end of this but
since I've made that Kevin Feige has
publicly come out and clarified what
that ship was he says we call it the
sanctuary - if that name doesn't sound
familiar to you and you're not freaking
out
sanctuary is the location of fan OSes
home base inside the black quadrant like
you look at this subtitle here for
guardians of the galaxy it says
sanctuary in the comics he has a giant
spaceship it looks like this I mean he's
had a bunch of different versions of it
there's no official name to it so
without being super on the knows about
it he's saying yeah that's pretty much
Stannis that's the ship you'll probably
see him in at the beginning of infinity
war even though if you've seen that
Comic Con footage he's in a slightly
different ship and he sort of portals in
when you see him in the scenes fighting
Avengers but that's because he has the
space stone in the important thing to
remember if you have seen that Comic Con
footage is is that when he's wielding
the gauntlet using it against the
Avengers like he
hooks a piece of meteorite at the event
like he rips it off of a moon and throws
it at them the gauntlet that he's
wearing doesn't have all the stones in
it so it's possible that he doesn't
assemble all six stones before the end
of Infinity Ward they might actually
legit save the soul stone for Avengers 4
because one of the big differences
between infinity war and Avengers 4 is
that in Avengers 4 Captain Marvel will
be joining the fight and although
they're gonna change her backstory a
little bit there's always the
possibility they could tie her powers to
an infinity stone although the soul
stone is a little bit different from
Captain Marvel's powers in the comics
her main claim to fame is that she can
absorb pretty much any type of energy
and redirected if she absorbs enough
energy she can assume her binary form
which sort of empowers her with a
version of the Phoenix force like she
just has this crazy cosmic level ability
she's not quite as powerful as the
Phoenix but binary form Captain Marvel
is one of the most powerful beings in
the Marvel Universe which is why Kevin
Feige has been hyping her up so much so
if we don't see that during the Captain
Marvel solo film will probably see
binary form Captain Marvel
during Avengers 4 when she's fighting
Thanos but just running down the list so
far the tesseract at the end of Thor
Ragnarok we see Loki steal it from
Odin's vault pocketed and then we get
that post-credit scene we saw Loki with
the tesseract on planet Earth during the
infinity war trailer at Comic Con
meaning that either he jumps away before
Thanos can get to them or he uses that
to get his people away because we see
Thor faceplant on the Milano so at some
point he's floating through the vacuum
of space but I think the idea is is that
Thanos tries to take the gem from him
Thor tries to fight him off because he's
unlocked his Thor force by the end of
the movie fan oohs still pounds him like
a rag doll and you see him floating in
space until he hits the Milano but the
next gem the aether the reality stone
was last seen with the collector just
assume if you haven't seen one of the
Infinity stones since it was last given
to someone assume that that person still
has it so obviously the mine stone is
still envisions forhead the power stone
is still with the Nova Corps the time
stone is in the eye of agamotto
currently being warned around
dr. Strange's neck during thor ragnarok
I've been falling for 30 minutes I know
it seemed like they gave him a major
power upgrade with a way he was able to
one-up Loki
even though Loki has magic in the way
that Doctor Strange has magic he calls
him a sorcerer and charges him with
those knives they were mostly doing that
for comedy but it'd be interesting to
see them actually try to weave spells
against one another but if you assume
that both Loki and dr. strange are
wielding infinity gems and they would
probably be relatively evenly matched
but I think for the most part the idea
is is that dr. strange is the most
powerful magic user on the planet right
now but from the looks of it we see no
soul stone to be found in the thing
about the stones is that they're
typically hidden inside other objects in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe so on the
off chance that they do include the soul
stone in black panther there are a
number of ways they could weave that
into the logic and the lore of Wakanda
like they have something called the
Dajjal EO which is sort of like an
astral plane where souls go when you die
is an actual place that you can travel
to when you see black panther against
the purple sky in this area here in the
trailer that's where he is like he's
getting ready to talk to his father the
spirit of his father they could use that
as a version of the soul stone because
within the soul stone is contained this
special realm so the ideas of the
afterlife soul stones is very endemic to
the black panther character in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe but because
you typically find stones inside of
other things in the movies they could
tie it to the vibranium if it wasn't
clear what conda's vibranium is taken
from a meteorite that crashed there
thousands of years ago so they've been
using it it's been leaching into the
soil that's where you get the
heart-shaped herb from so black panther
gets a lot of his special abilities
because a lot of these plants have been
growing in vibranium tainted soil for
this whole time the meteorite itself is
called the Menon guy they don't know
where it came from they only know it's
alien in origin so it's always possible
that the soul stone could have been
inside that meteorite but I think it's
more likely that they'll just save the
soul stone for infinity war in Avengers
4 and we won't see any Infinity stone
inside black panther vibranium by itself
is power
enough to be really special in the Black
Panther movie looks so unique he just
demands your attention in a way that the
other movies haven't did a little while
so honestly I don't think that they need
an infinity stone to get people's asses
into the theater to see the movie like
usually when you hear there's going to
be an infinity stone you get really
excited that's become less and less of a
thing in the last couple of movies like
spider-man homecoming they had the
brand-new suit people were excited to
see then they unfurled a whole new one
at the end of the movie know infinity
stone to be found so we know that
Avengers infinity war is going to be
sort of a 70's style heist movie with
Thanos going around taking the gems from
the Avengers with the help of the Black
Order but given the way they've been
treating all the Infinity stones for the
last couple of movies it just feels like
they're gonna save all of the soul
stones stuff for those two movies but
let me know in the comments do you think
that they will actually save the soul
stone for infinity war given that Thanos
does not have all of the stones in the
Infinity Gauntlet when he's fighting the
Avengers in that trailer that we've seen
already the whole idea and they've since
confirmed this is that there will be a
bunch of Avengers Thanos follow up it's
just that the first part of infinity war
is going to be the heist movie Avengers
4 will be more of like the legit Thanos
Infinity Gauntlet saga where you see him
actually using it to change things about
the universe so what will happen is I'll
post my Easter Egg video next that
should be up later tonight the Thor
ticket giveaway is still going on you
can use the gift certificate for any
movie that you want all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video congratulations to
the latest giveaway winner Chris Jordan
please private message me so I can get
your contact details you can click here
for that post credit scene video and you
can click here to learn about the new
Terminator style Superman TV show thank
you so much for watching everyone
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight